كوين آمون هو تخصص خاص
بشمال فرنسا مشتق من
كلمات العصا للزبدة والكعك ، النسبة
لهذه المعجنات خاصة ، إنها زبدة في
الواقع إنها 30 بالمائة زبدة و 30
بالمائة سكر
[موسيقى]
مرحبًا بكم في مدينة رينيه التي يبلغ عدد
سكانها  حوالي 15000 هذه
المدينة الساحلية الصغيرة بها عدد قليل من عوامل الجذب الرئيسية
بما في ذلك التجول في السواحل
وزيارة متحف الميناء ورؤية
Chapelle of San Michele ولكن هذا ليس
سبب
وجودنا هنا لمقابلة Terry Luca الرجل
الذي يمكنك التحدث إليه عندما تريد
كريم حلويات كوين عمّان الأصيل حقًا على
AT&T متنوع Romany Sangha ليكون فارغًا
أيضًا ، كانت الأسطورة تقول أن الخباز نفد من
البضائع في متجره واضطر إلى تحضير
شيء ما بسرعة والجلوس في حفلة
أشعر بالقلق من
Kisuke Larry Sugarman في الفول السوداني
فطيرة الزبدة هي طائر جميل ، هل يمكنك إطلاق النار علي
؟  عادل ، ما الذي حصلت عليه
عبر mondo يسيطر على سن
كمية لا بأس بها من Nutella pot Omega by Omega 6
seconds على devel
Avila pot يجب أن تفعله - كلما كان
لديك نبيذ عطري ،
فأنت تعلم أن التجميع الحلو غالبًا ما يتم وضعه بشكل
فردي أريد أن يمارس المترو اللعنة عليك
أعطي معروفًا ، هل سيكون يا كريم صلبًا
كما تراه نعم إذا كنت تريد أن
يكون كبيرًا جدًا لضبط نغمة
ابن عم السياج 30 تحت الصفر هو منزل قطة ثانٍ
في اسم نوم ، قل ما هو المفهوم الذي
أريد التحدث إليه  دانتي ،
إنه بالتأكيد علاج ربما ليس
شيئًا تأكله كل يوم
أفضل أن أغادر هنا لأذهب السيد.
بسبب النغمة المتذبذبة قليلاً أو كنت فقط
خائفًا ومثل تاجرًا
تقليديًا كان علي أن أجبر عبارة هنا
آه آه آه آه آه لذلك لأرتدي بدلة تزلج لأنني
لست أنت في المحيط من فضلك يادا يادا
نعم ، ليس لديك الكلمة الأخيرة ، لكن من
الواضح أننا جربناها لسنا من
تينا وأعتقد أن وجهنا يقول كل شيء
وأيضًا هذه الملاحظة العفوية يا
إلهي ، هذا مغرور جدًا ،
يمكنك أن تجذبني عشرة من أصل عشرة ستوصي